Gwen Stefani's kids share an adorable
Christmas tradition while their mama
stuns on stage with boyfriend Blake
Shelton's this is just magical the 48
year old singer looked happy as ever
during her you make me feel like
Christmas special which aired on NBC
Tuesday and you could definitely feel
the love as boyfriend Blake Shelton took
the stage alongside her to perform
[Music]
when stunned in several outfit changes
throughout the night which included a
Santa inspired costume a peppermint
present and a stunning red ball gown but
the most memorable moment would have to
be when Gwen's kids 11 year old Kingston
nine year old Zuma and three year old
Apollo shared their sweet family
tradition or Santa puts wrapping paper
over the door that leads to their
Christmas tree and presents we try to
look underneath it and see this stuff
but it's always it's always super close
to the floor so we usually don't get to
see anything you run and then Wayne good
closer to them you know you can break it
out I don't know how Santa thought that
up is such a good idea
[Music]
you
[Music]